[Musik]
bild breaking news
an guten morgen und wir beginnen gleich
mit breaking news ja wirklich
dramatische szenen die sich am abend in
solingen abgespielt haben bei einer
tödlichen messerstecherei der stirbt ein
31 jähriger und ein weiterer mann
offenbar der vater des opfers der wird
schwer verletzt unsere reporter haben
exklusive augenzeugen videos
schreie in der dunkelheit stimmengewirr
die hassel straße in solingen am abend
tatort einer tödlichen messerstecherei
am späten abend die vier in solingen
eine größere personengruppe in streit
geraten ein mann soll dann ein messer
gezogen haben und hat dem späteren opfer
die klingel mehrfach in den körper
gerammt die stiche trafen den mann in
herz und den hals er biete noch einige
momente stehen und sagte dann
blutüberströmt zusammen
zeugen und der herbeigerufene notarzt
versuchen noch die person zu reanimieren
doch jede hilfe kommt zu spät das opfer
stirbt noch am tatort mindestens eine
weitere person wird durch stiche
verletzt offenbar der vater des
getöteten wenig später wird der
mutmaßliche täter von der polizei
festgenommen wir haben dann umfangreiche
fahndungsmaßnahmen
eingeleitet im rahmen dieser
fahndungsmaßnahmen konnten die beamten
auch eine männliche tatverdächtige
person vorläufig festnehmen die art und
weise der beteiligung an dieser
auseinandersetzung ist derzeit noch
gegenstand der ermittlungen ebenso die
hintergründe und zu dem sachverhalt was
ist hier eigentlich passiert ist derzeit
noch sehr unklar die kriminalpolizei
sperrt den tatort weiträumig ab zur
spurensicherung und auch weil immer mehr
familienangehörige am ort des schreckens
eintreffen eine mordkommission hat die
ermittlungen aufgenommen und wir
beginnen mit unbegreiflichen szenen nach
einem schrecklichen lkw unfall auf der
a2 in brandenburg
es sind bilder die fassungslos machen
mit kippe und bierflasche stehen diese
männer neben der autobahn und gaffen
während sich wenige meter entfernt
grausame szenen abspielen auf der a2 kam
es zu einem schweren unfall ein brummi
fahrer sitzt in seinem lkw eingeklemmt
die rettungskräfte können den man nicht
befreien er verbrennt bei lebendigem
leib diese männer schauen zu dürfen
trinken bier und haben nichts besseres
zu tun als dabei zuzusehen wie ein mann
in seinem fahrerhaus verbrennt auf der
a2 in brandenburg in höhe berlin war es
zu einem furchtbaren unfall gekommen ein
lkw fahrer hatte wohl aus unachtsamkeit
das stauende übersehen und krachte auf
einen stehenden omi der geht sofort in
flammen auf die flammen schlagen um sich
explosionen für den fahrer kommt jede
hilfe zu spät der fahrer verbrennt im
führerhaus
widerlich während sich dieses drama
abspielt stehen diese männer wenige
meter entfernt machen sich auch noch
lustig beleidigen die einsatzkräfte und
zeigen um den stinkefinger die
rettungskräfte können das verhalten
dieser männer nicht fassen da drüben die
zwei bürger die stehen ja am
wildschutzzaun an der b2 müssen
vermutlich durch den wald hier reinigung
sein und stehen da drüben märz mit einer
flasche bier in der hand teilweise
brauchen die dort im wald bei warnstufe
5 zigarette wie gesagt und beleidigen
hier die einsatzkräfte mit mittelfinger
also es geht gar nicht so persönlich
macht es mich natürlich auch innerlich
aggressiv wir sind ja alle ehrenamtlich
wir haben familien zu hause wir haben
andere sachen zu tun auch privat weh und
deshalb traurig dass vom bürger nicht
mal irgendwie der nötige respekt da ist
dass leute ihre freizeit opfern um
anderen menschen das leben zu retten
deutliche worte aber nicht nur die
rettungskräfte auch die autofahrer
verurteilung das kreiste und pietätlose
verhalten der unglaublich dreist gaffer
an der a 2 das kann ich überhaupt nicht
verstehen ich habe mich wirklich ruhig
im auto verhalten habe hier abgewartet
und möchte keinen weg sein weil da geht
es teilweise um leben und das kann ich
nicht behindern und erst recht nicht die
leute in ihrer arbeiter beleidigen weil
die machen das ehrenamtlich und
freiwillig der unfall ist gerade vor mir
passiert ich bin immer sehr dankbar wenn
die kollegen von der freiwilligen
feuerwehr hier sind es gab richtig
heftige explosionen nach zehn minuten
kamen die ersten rettungskräfte stehen
der ersten reihe und bin sehr dankbar
dass
ein brummifahrer verbrennt in seinem lkw
und diese männer schauen zu trinken wir
brauchen und verhöhnen die
rettungskräfte
gaffen obwohl es eigentlich geächtet ist
passiert das immer wieder und ein mann
ist der wohl dreisteste gaffer
deutschland ergibt sich nämlich als
gutachter aus
dreister geht es kaum hier gibt sich an
cover als gutachter aus
der nordring in nürnberg als ein junger
fahrer verbotswidrig wendet kann ein
nachfolgender motorradfahrer nicht mehr
rechtzeitig ausweichen
der 32-jährige rast mit seiner maschine
in das auto wird durch die luft
geschleudert und landet auf der anderen
straßenseite der biker kommt mit
lebensgefährlichen verletzungen ins
krankenhaus ebenso wie der leicht
verletzte fahrer
und dann das während die polizei die
unfallstelle sichert und zeugen befragt
taucht auf einmal ein mann auf und macht
fotos auf nachfrage gibt er sich als
gutachter aus eine dreiste lüge die
beamten warten zwar auf einem
sachverständigen doch die ihn kennen sie
in der regel und diesen mann kennt ihn
niemand
sofort greift eine polizistin ein
kontrolliert die personalien des mannes
und fordert ihn auf die ihm gemachten
fotos zu löschen
wir haben aber die haben aber alle
fühlen
sie wacht man das gestern für einen
umzug ich bin fit machen
ich verstand machen bilder
ein weiterer beamter kommt dazu und
stellt sicher dass die coverbilder auch
wirklich und endgültig gelöscht werden
erst dann könne man den unfallort
verlassen
von einsicht allerdings keine spur der
kräftigen einfach interessiert
die genaue unfallursache ist noch nicht
bekannt die verkehrspolizei nürnberg hat
die ermittlungen übernommen
auch ob der gaffer mit rechtlichen
konsequenzen rechnen muss ist unklar
auch heute wieder ein wunderbarer tag
herrlichstem sommerwetter hitze
eigentlich das heißeste jahr seit
jahrzehnten haben wir in diesem jahr
besser als ihre schattenseiten ja
ständig immer wieder brechen feuer aus
auch hier bei uns in deutschland knapp
eine woche nach ausbruch des feuers auf
dem sprengplatz im berliner grunewald
da ist allerdings die sperrung der
stadtautobahn avus nun endlich wieder
aufgehoben worden heißt aufatmen der
hauptstadt sich den rest der menschen in
deutschland egal aber tatsächlich ist
das nur um eine dimension klappen eine
der wichtigsten aller dann sozusagen in
die stadt rein verkehrsadern die war
jetzt die ganze zeit gesperrt
riesenchaos immer wieder war es zu
unkontrollierten explosionen auf diesen
sprengplatz im grunewald gekommen tja
und dann bild reportern ist es
allerdings nun gelungen einen der lösch
roboter in dieses hochgefährliche gebiet
zu begleiten die bilder zeigen jetzt
bild in der verbotenen zone im grunewald
herrscht auch gut eine woche nach den
brennt nun explosionen immer noch große
alarmbereitschaft ein rein kommen in den
550 meter stärk kreis ist nur mit
gepanzerten fahrzeugen möglich
denn jede sekunde könnte es knallt
mitten im grunewald befindet sich das
lager der polizei hof und bomben und
munition aufbewahrt werden tagelang
erschütterten explosionen das gebiet
brennende breiten sich aus können kaum
unter kontrolle gebracht werden
beim betreten des sperrgebiets erklärt
die feuerwehr man darf niemals und unter
keinen umständen die wege verlassen es
bleibt brandgefährlich
seit dienstagabend sind auch
hubschrauber der bundespolizei im
einsatz im minuten-takt werfen sie 2000
liter wasser über dem sperrgebiet ab
vereinzelt steigen noch rauch wolken auf
es bleibt immer noch gefährlich deshalb
kommt zunehmend technik zum einsatz
seines roboter kreuzen die geräumten
wege
auch im einsatz der bergepanzer t 55
sowjetischer bauart aus sachsen-anhalt
er soll dafür sorgen dass sich flammen
nicht weiter ausbreiten können
zwischen noch gesunden bäumen sieht man
vor allem verkohlte baumstümpfe der
boden ist abgebrannt auch gesunde bäume
werden sterben erklärt das forstamt
ohnewald
das bild reporter team darf bis auf etwa
300 meter an den springplatz rang ab da
herrscht striktes fotografier und
filmverbot
denn jede aufnahme könnte den waldbrand
und explosionen wieder lostreten
für die einsatzkräfte zählt nur eins
schadensbegrenzung im wald der mit aus
bislang 50 hektar nicht 320 werden
ja wir müssen wir richten über eine
messerattacke mitten in einem
ausländeramt zwar auf eine mitarbeiterin
passiert ist diese wahnsinnstat in
wuppertal elberfeld am frühen morgen
griff dort ein 21 jähriger syrer die
frau wenn man stimmte ins sogenannte
haus der integration dort sprang der
angreifer im eingangsbereich über den
empfangstresen und stach dann
unvermittelt auf die frau ein der
sicherheitsdienst der konnte ihn dann
schließlich überwältigen der mann wurde
später von der polizei festgenommen
die frau ist inzwischen im krankenhaus
wie schwer sie verletzt ist ist derzeit
noch unklar im haus der integration hin
sowohl der jobcenter als auch das
ausländeramt untergebracht und
zugeschaltet wo portal ist uns jetzt
andreas wegener unser reporter vor ort
und was kannst du uns zu den
hintergründen der tat sagen
ja man muss einfach sagen zu den
hintergründen kann noch nicht viel
gesagt werden man muss sich überlegen
diese tat dies kann hier gut vier
stunden her der junge mann der
festgenommen worden ist der wird jetzt
durch anwälte beraten die zeugen sind
zum teil traumatisiert und konnte noch
nicht befragt werden insofern muss man
vielleicht verständnis haben dass die
kripo da mit schnellen antworten noch
nicht dabei ist was aber auch klar ist
der tatort hier dass seine ausländer
würde und in der ausländerbehörde da
geht es natürlich für die leute die da
hilfe suchen um existenzielle sachen da
geht es ums bleiberecht zum beispiel und
da kommt es natürlich häufiger mal zu
streit und deshalb ist ja eben auch
dieser sicherheitsdienst hier schon seit
langer zeit beschäftigt weiß man denn
inzwischen etwas zum zustand der frau
wie es ihr geht schwebt in lebensgefahr
ja da gab es zum glück entwarnung aus
dem krankenhaus also ich habe gerade
noch mal mit der polizei gesprochen es
sieht wohl so aus dass sie schwer
verletzt ist da jetzt behandelt wird
aber zum glück muss ich nicht befürchten
dass sie stirbt muss niemand befürchten
dass sie stirbt insofern das kann man
jetzt schon sagen aber weitere details
werden moment halt auch nämlich bekannt
gegeben also eine messerattacke
ausgerechnet im haus der integration
was natürlich von bitterer ironie es in
der andreas wegner
sollte schauen wir aber erstmal auf
krimmel touran wladimir putin und seine
barbaren regierung die versuchen nämlich
weiterhin die russen bevölkerung im
unklaren über ihre völkerrechtswidrigen
angriffskrieg auf die ukraine aber mit
der propaganda ist das so eine sache das
kann auch nach hinten losgehen
die russische propaganda maschinerie
läuft auf hochtouren klingt erstmal nach
profis doch anscheinend sind im land der
fake news ziemliche dilettanten am werk
wie hier die neueste meisterleistung
putin and i muss und ex präsident
dimitri medwedew besucht vor kurzem die
russischen truppen in der region
orenburg dabei soll er laut der
russischen nachrichtenagentur tass auch
truppenübungen beobachtet haben dazu
verbreiteten die kreml medien dieses
foto von mit video der haken der
vize-chef des sicherheitsrates konnte
gar nicht sehen die klappen seines
fernglases versperrten die sicht bild
zeigt ihnen die top 5 peinlichsten
propagandafilms der russen seit
kriegsbeginn platz fünf sim-karten fail
im april sorgte dieses foto für
ordentlich lacher im netz hier wurde
laut ihren geheimdienst fsb ein neonazi
festgenommen gefunden wurden unter
anderem sechs sprengsätze acht
molotow-cocktails sechs pistole eine
granate mehr als 1000 patronen drogen
und gefälschte ukrainische besser doch
eines ist ziemlich auffällig auf den gut
präparierten propaganda fotos zwischen
hakenkreuz t shirt und neonazi literatur
lag feind drapiert drei
erweiterungspakete des beliebten
computerspiel sims 3
vermutlich wurde von einem
geheimdienstler die einkaufsliste falsch
verstanden statt drei sim-karten auf
russisch triesen wurden drei
computerspiele gekauft platz vier
peinliche propaganda show im mai fuhr
der kreml mächtig auf mit einer mega
propaganda schutz um 8 jährigen jubiläum
der annexion der krim im moskauer
olympiastadion luschniki hielt kreml
diktator putin eine rede an die nation
doch etwas wie tief die putin rede wurde
im tv live übertragen als mitten im satz
die propaganda show ein jähes ende fand
aus dem kreml hieß es etwa eine halbe
stunde nach der unterbrechung es habe
einen serverfehler gegeben ziemlich
schnell für die propaganda die tanten
platz drei bonnie und clyde im russen tv
zum jahrestag des sieges der sowjetunion
über nazi deutschland am 9 mai strahlte
der russische sender channel one sein
traditionelles konzert aus aber ein foto
zog die ganze zeremonie ins lächerliche
im hintergrund der bühne wurden alte
schwarz weiß bilder lächelnder
russischer paare von 1945 gezeigt
plötzlich jedoch ein foto des
berühmtesten verbrecher pärchens der
amerikanischen geschichte bonnie und
clyde
platz zwei flugzeugträger der jüngste
patzer instrument in westsibirien wurden
plakate aufgehängt um den tag der
russischen marine zu feiern im zentrum
eines der plakate zu sehen ein
flugzeugträger umrankt von russischen
marine flaggen die überschrift alles
gute zum tag der marine blöd nur dass
das auf den plakaten abgebildete
kriegsschiff gar nicht von der
russischen marine ist die dort
abgebildete uss age double you busch ist
ein flugzeugträger der united states
navy und gehört somit den amerikanern
nicht den russen
platz eins moskwa gleicher tag andere
panne diesmal von einer russischen
zeitung in baschkortostan gratulierte
die regionalzeitung ihren lesern zum tag
der russischen marine unveröffentlichte
dazu auf seiner website ein foto des
kreuzers moskwa über dem die weiß-blaue
marine flagge wehte die überschrift
heute ist der tag der russischen marine
peinlich aber die moskwa liegt auf dem
meeresgrund putins flaggschiff übrigens
das größte russische kriegsschiff seit
dem zweiten weltkrieg wurde von der
ukraine am 14 april versenkt das
bestätigte an jenem abend auch das
verteidigungsministerium in moskau
damals war die zerstörung der moskwa
eine peinliche klatsche für putin in
seinem blutigen überfall auf die ukraine
ja ja ja das dürften im kreml so gar
nicht gefallen da müssen wir natürlich
noch mal drüber sprechen mit einem der
sich auskennt chefreporter peter tiede
peter also diese russische propaganda
maschine die gilt auch eigentlich als
wahnsinnig mächtig als erfahren wie kann
es sein dass man tatsächlich solche
fenster ständig passieren dass am ende
des tages komplett egal es sind die von
morgens bis abends lieb sein kann es
auch mal ein falsches bild zeigen und es
ist tatsächlich völlig egal die
hauptsache ist dass es bei 80 prozent
der leute über 90 prozent der leute
verhängt das ist dann fehlt sind das ist
ein fake sind das feld die wenigsten
robusten auf das erfahren dann auch die
wenigsten rosen hauptsache die bilder
stellen das würde gerade fragen jetzt
erfährt dass keiner das dass anna-maria
ich meine bonnie and clyde soria
der großen parade bonnie clyde das muss
doch irgendwie das musste ich doch es
gibt es geht dann wird dann viral und es
gilt ja dann auch wieder als sympathisch
dass ihr die propaganda angewiesen
mächtige propaganda maschinen doch nicht
allmächtig ist dann sagt man guckt mal
so schlimm kann es ja gar nicht sein und
kann ja nicht alles kann ich alles
kontrolliert sein es zeigt aber auch
dass es vielen menschen auch die in die
apparate arbeiten die der propaganda
wird schlicht und ergreifend total egal
ist was sie da wirklich zeigen also
nehmen wir mal den flugzeugträger jetzt
kannst du mit einem russischen
flugzeugträger auch echt nicht angeben
die admiral kusnezow das ist der einzige
russische flugzeugträger man besitzt
tatsächlich nur ein der ist noch zu
sowjetzeiten gebaut waren auf einer
werft ausgerechnet in der heutigen
ukraine und das ding kannst du nicht
vorzeigen wenn der durch die weltmeere
fährt kennen wir die bilder da ist ein
riesengroßer rußwolke über die mehr weil
diese weil dieser uralte uralte
flugzeugträger ersten ständig kaputt ist
verhältnissen alte maschinen hat und
drittens wirklich nichts taugt der fall
noch die flugzeuge runter dann nimmt man
besser wenn man schon einen zeigen will
den amerikanischen flugzeugträger die
haben nichts vernünftiges aber
ausgerechnet das müsste doch dann
eigentlich auffallen wenn man nur ein
hat und der so unterschiedliche aussieht
und dann nimmt man ausgerechnet so ein
top stück der amerikaner da müsste man
doch auch mit rechnen dass die amis
irgendwie drauf reagieren oder ja aber
wenn die amis reagieren heißt es nicht
dass die nachricht auch in tiefen
russland ankommt und bei der werbung
draußen auf dem land ankommt da kommst
nicht an die kugel ins internet die ist
nicht bei twitter facebook ist ohnehin
gesperrt facebook und twitter auch und
wie gesagt die hauptsache ist die
meisten leute denken dass man toll ist
und die leute fahren ja auch im rostigen
kaputt dadurch über alte kaputte straßen
durch kaputte steht oder dörfer und nach
hinten drauf den aufkleber wir haben den
zweiten weltkrieg gewonnen nach berlin
die hauptsache ist die bilder stimmen
die propaganda überschriften stimmen wie
es im land aussieht was da gezeigt wird
egal aktueller fall ja auch die krim da
sagt russland ja das sei ein brand in
einem munitionslager ausgebrochen es
gibt jetzt aktuelle bilder die zeigen
vorher nachher da ist also ein
luftwaffenstützpunkt bombardiert worden
mutmaßlich eben von ukrainischer seite
auf enstar keine offizielle bestätigung
gibt da sieht man aber dramatische
schäden tatsächlich sind sieben jets
kampfjets die dort stationiert waren
sind mit einem schlag kaputt ja und die
kampfjets die kann man zur not noch
ersetzen aber das was man links und
rechts gilt gesehen hat wie nämlich
wirklich panikartig die leute die
strände auf der krim verlassen haben und
dann auch die krim verlassen haben es
gibt bilder von der krim brücke da
fahren die touristen nur in eine einzige
richtung die gegenrichtung auf die krim
die ist leer und auf der anderen seite
herrscht stau das in das vertrauen
verloren gegangen da haben die russen
zum ersten mal gespürt buch der krieg
findet jedoch bei uns statt uns in den
führungs zeichen weil die krim ist
ukrainische staatsgebiet es ist ein
großes bild besetzt aber dann macht man
lustig ferien 2014 ich war ein paar mal
da hat mir das auch angeguckt weil auch
baden und da macht man patriotischen
urlaub und jetzt mitten in den
patriotischen urlaub kleinen die ukraine
mutmaßlich mit einem angriff rein und
dass die ukraine regelmäßig schon mal
auch russisches staatsgebiet nicht nur
jetzt die krim die er besetzte grimm
angegriffen haben habe ich selber mal
erlebt also schon nach zwei wochen krieg
ist ein militärflughafen auf der
russischen seite angegriffen und von der
ukrainischen drohne also zeit dass die
russen merken dass sie tatsächlich krieg
haben danke dir für deine einschätzung
bei uns ist bild chefreporter peter
tiede peter du hast da auch die ganze
pressekonferenz verfolgt dein erster
eindruck ein sowie nadja das gesagt hat
ein erhöhter kanzler ein bewusst auch so
auftreten der kanzler würde man sagen er
hat den yoga kanzler gegeben also
wirklich entspannung in zeiten von
krisen er hat quasi vielleicht bewussten
kontrapunkt gesetzt zum beispiel zu den
grünen die vor sozialen unruhen waren
und die davon ausgehen dass es
tatsächlich ein sehr heißer herbst auch
auf der straße werden werden werden
könnte da hat er den den kanzler der
frisch aus dem urlaub kommt gegeben und
den familienvater der irgendwie sagt
leute macht euch immer keine
sorgenkinder jeder kriegt ne kugel
leisten das war also der rote faden der
dadurch geführt hat heute und man muss
sagen ja diese eine stunde 47 die ganze
veranstaltung gedauert hat tatsächlich
patzer frei über die bühne gebracht
allerdings auch wirklich fast schon
charme frei bei angela merkel gab es
immer mal so nach momenten komischen hat
es nicht gegeben okay wir haben wir
haben krise und scholz ist halt ein
bisschen schneller fast zwei stunden von
journalisten die alle natürlich hart
nachfragen anteil
das ist ein das ist ein format in dem
gewinnt immer der kanzler bei jeder
journalist hat eine frage eine nachfrage
erste frage nicht beantworten zweite
frage nicht richtig beantworten schon
bisher aussage und der kollege ist das
mikro los ist das mikrofon los dazu
kommt dann noch die auslandspresse die
auch noch mal ganz spezielle fragen hat
zu arabien zu anderen sachen wo der
kanzler immer mal durchatmen kann wo er
sich nochmal überlegen kann wenn jetzt
noch mal ne frage kommt was sage ich
dann darauf also gehen wir mal durch ja
wir wollen auf die erste kugel eis
schauen so wie du es genannt hast da gab
es nämlich gleich mal ein versprechen
einen sogenannten merkel moment
also gucken was müssen wir machen damit
diejenigen die arbeiten aber nicht so
geld verdienen dass sie die teure
einheitspreise und wohnungspreise
finanzieren können unterstützen das ist
die wohngeld frage wir sollten überlegen
was ist jetzt mit dem bürgergeld reform
das richtige wir sollten überlegen was
können wir tun im hinblick auf rentner
oder studenten
was können wir tun für diejenigen die
wenig verdienen und deshalb von den
steuerentlastungen nicht zu viel haben
und was können wir für die tun bei denen
die steuerentlastung genau das richtige
instrument ist dann rechnen wir das
zusammen und gucken ob uns das leisten
können mein gefühl sagt wir werden das
können
popstar ist der markt im moment etwas
geschaffen das klingt schon sehen können
das so wir können uns das leisten der
kanzler sagt also erzählt alles auf was
auf den tisch ist was aus seiner partei
kommt von den grünen kommt und auch was
christian lindner vorgestellt hat
steuerentlastung und er sagt am ende wir
werden das zusammenrechnen und mein
gefühl sagt mir wir können das wir
können uns das leisten das ist ein markt
im moment bei frage 3 schon relativ früh
hat er ein versprechen abgegeben an die
deutschen wir können uns diese krise
leisten wir werden sie dadurch für ein
geld ist für alle da und das ist auch
eine ansage in seiner ampel rein jeder
kriegt er seine kugel eis die grünen die
spd und die fdp in unmittelbaren
zusammenhang damit natürlich auch die
angst vor sozialen unruhen du hast
gesagt die grünen nahmen ist
angesprochen kommt die heiz krise im
winter muss man frieren kann man sich
kein strom mehr lassen auch dass er sich
geäußert werden
unsere wirtschaftslage ist ja
gegenwärtig trotz dieser schwierigkeiten
davon gekennzeichnet dass wir eine hohe
beschäftigung haben und sie sogar weiter
steigt und deshalb glaube ich haben wir
alle chancen gut durch diese zeit zu
kommen auch wenn es schwierig wird
wer muss man fast nichts sagen der
kanzler sagt wir kommen dadurch aber es
wird nicht einfach das ist quasi das was
er über den winter und das nächste jahr
sagt er spricht nicht nur bedingungen
über dem winter also es kann dauern die
nächsten monate werden nicht leicht aber
sagen wir so um niemand stürzt total ab
es werden viele leute abrutschen in
sozialhilfe in die in soziale wärme zb
in wohngeld in staatliche leistungen die
darauf angewiesen waren aber da kannst
du auch die kohle reicht aber es soll ja
hilfen geben da hat sich ja zum beispiel
auch christian lindner jetzt ein schönes
steuerentlastungspaket ausgedacht da hat
er sich aus zu geäußert aber ich glaube
christian lindner wird nicht gefallen
haben was er gesagt hat
und das will ich auch hier noch einmal
wiederholen das gilt für ganz ganz viele
bürger in bürger es gibt mehr um
diejenigen die 28 vertrieben 3200 euro
brutto 104000 euro für die das alles
große herausforderungen sind und deshalb
ist klar dass zu dem gesamtpaket das wir
ergreifen werden sicherlich auch
steuerlichen entlastungsmaßnahmen dazu
gehören der finanzminister hat seinen
beitrag zu den notwendigen überlegungen
dazu gestern vorgestellt ich finde das
sehr sehr hilfreich
der finanzminister hat seinen beitrag
gestern vorgelegt man muss nicht mal vor
augen führen dass der chef der fdp der
bundesvorsitzende der freien
demokratischen partei deutschlands und
finanzminister dieses landes gestern in
seinem ministerium eine große
pressekonferenz abgehalten hat und
verkündet hat 48 millionen deutsche
werden steuerlich entlastet werden
der kanzler findet das hilfreich und er
hat ihm dann quasi auch eingenordet und
hat ihn auch einsortiert also das was
christian lindner gestern groß gemacht
hat vor der pressekonferenz des
bundeskanzlers heute hat der bundestag
und dann eingeordnet in wohngeld diese
sachen rentner und studenten und
steuerlichen entlastung also christian
lindner ist ins glied gepfiffen worden
hat einen wichtigen beitrag geleistet
darf ihn auch weiter machen aber es ist
nur allenstein von ganz vielen sei eine
klatsche für christian lindner sodann
ging es natürlich auch um das thema
comics ziemlich brisant muss man sagen
steuerhinterziehung in millionen
milliarden höhe und da ging es natürlich
auch um die frage was wusste was weiß
scholz steuer tricksereien genau
ich habe zu diesen dingen ja sehr
umfangreich und viele stunden lang
stellung genommen und werde das wieder
tun ich habe
die auskünfte gegeben die möglich sind
aber ich will gerne ihre frage als
gelegenheit benutzen einmal auf
folgendes freundlich hinzuweisen das ist
jetzt seit zweieinhalb jahren ein thema
der journalistin für alle möglichen die
an dem thema arbeiten auch für den
ausschuss in hamburg es sind unglaublich
viele personen gehört worden das sind
unglaublich viele akten studiert worden
und wenn man jetzt die
presseberichterstattung über die
jeweiligen anhörungen anderes verfolgt
dann ist immer das ergebnis es hat keine
beeinflussung durch die politik gegeben
was die entscheidung betrifft ich bin
sicher dass diese erkenntnis nicht mehr
verändert werden wird nach zweieinhalb
jahren ist das ganz klar
ja also vielleicht muss man auch ganz
kurz sagen scholz hat ja selber auch
schon aussagen müssen es geht um seine
zeit als er
regierender bürgermeister erster
bürgermeister in hamburg war es geht um
die warburg-bank der angeblich mit hilfe
der politik fast 50 millionen an steuern
erlassen worden sein soll rückzahlungen
die eigentlich nötig gewesen da steht
der vorwurf im raum dass olaf scholz
daran aktiv beteiligt war dass sie die
warburg bank entweder direkt oder
indirekt an ihn gewandt hat und er dafür
gesorgt hat dass die hamburger ist unter
ihnen zumindest dafür gesorgt worden ist
dass die hamburger steuerbehörden eine
später nicht mehr zu halten eine
entscheidung getroffen haben nämlich
lisa wirklich angesehenen hamburger
privatbank und sehr einflussreichen
privatbank 47 millionen euro zu erlassen
so olaf scholz sagt daran wird sich
nichts mehr ändern an den erkenntnissen
man muss dazu sagen dass der kanzler mit
diesem satz eigentlich nur sagt an
meinen erinnerungslücken wird sich
nichts ändern ich werde mich auch in
zukunft nicht ein wichtige gespräche die
ich jetzt hamburger bürgermeister
gefühlt habe erinnern können mein
beitrag ist geleistet nämlich keiner
nämlich olaf scholz leidet in diesen
zweieinhalb jahren die auch vor
untersuchungsausschüssen ausgesagt hat
und jetzt demnächst wieder aussagen muss
immer unter gedächtnislücken wird
entscheidend wird kann sich der
bundeskanzler früher nicht an seine zeit
und an gespräche als hamburger
regierender bürgermeister erinnerung
oder erster bürgermeister und daran wird
sich halt nichts ändern das sagt der
kanzler hiermit klipp und klar ich werde
mich nicht weiter genannten die
journalisten die können sich natürlich
erinnern haben dementsprechend natürlich
noch mal ein bisschen nachgehakt und
nachgefragt haben noch mal kurz rein
ich habe keinen anspruch darauf dass
irgendjemand mal sagt okay zweieinhalb
jahre habe ich es versucht rauszukriegen
ich habe es nicht geschafft aber ich
gebe zu ich bin ein mensch genoss ich
freute mich wenn das der ein oder andere
mal über sein herzblatt
6000 schätzen das ist recht der
bundeskanzler sagt ja einem
untersuchungsausschuss eines parlamentes
nämlich dem untersuchungsausschuss der
freien und hansestadt hamburg des
parlamentes ist dass er will dass man
aufhört und er sagt dass auch die
journalisten die dort sitzen und die im
berechtigte fragen stellen vielleicht
hat ja meine antwort drauf aber die will
hat nicht geben sondern erfordert dass
man aufhört er will dass der
untersuchungsausschuss nach zweieinhalb
jahren geht es erstmal gut sprechen
können trotzdem kriegt ich habe mich
erfolgreich nicht erinnert jetzt ist man
gut irgendwie und ihr journalisten ihr
könnt weiter fragen aber eigentlich doch
auch für und kommt nicht mehr raus das
gehört sich nicht macht man nicht ist
frech hat gehört sich nicht machbar
nicht frechheit ist die elegante
überleitung
groß
ja auch zu gerd schröder hat oder 40
geäußert
unsere wirtschaftslage ist ja
gegenwärtig trotz dieser schwierigkeiten
davon gekennzeichnet dass wir eine hohe
beschäftigung haben und sie sogar weiter
steigt und deshalb glaube ich haben wir
alle chancen gut durch diese zeit zu
kommen auch wenn es schwierig wird das
weiß nicht stolz kann man nicht aufgeben
will für 1 oder gar nicht oft genug
betonen das war noch mal der merkel
moment was hat dazu also schröder gesagt
er ist das gebracht worden auf nachfrage
von einem journalisten
ob den gerhard schröder noch mal
irgendwie gewusst und beitrag leisten
könnte für ihn so viel zu hektisch
russland ich wüsste nicht
gesagt das war dann so eine schöne
flapsige das war schon das wichtigste
ich wüsste nicht also quasi ein total
abfuhr an den alten kanzler sollte man
hannover in seinem häuschen sitzen und
dann zum kreml fahren aber der kanzler
setzt nicht mehr auf die light kanzler
vielleicht der einzige wirkliche
schmunzeln moment in dieser
pressekonferenz gab es nicht dankeschön
peter für deine einschätzung gern
[Musik]